Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, here is a caller
who is telling me I'm wrong. Donald
Trump didn't get arrested. Now,
you might be saying, David, when did you
say Trump got arrested? And of course,
the answer is never. Listen to the confusion here.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, it's Frank from Florida.
Yeah. Watching your segment on wondering if
Trump got arrested. Yeah. There's no way in
the world that that happened. Okay. And him being
quiet about it. Okay. He be screaming, holy hell.
So I doubt very much that's what happened.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I never said that Trump got
arrested. So the story Monday was Trump's
suddenly in D.C. unannounced trip. He's
just there. And there's speculation as to
why is he in D.C.? Because he's going to
get arrested. He's been told you have to turn
yourself in. Is he in D.C. because he is just
playing golf? So I never said maybe Trump got
arrested and nobody heard about it. Of course,
if Trump had gotten arrested, we would have heard
about it. The speculation was, has he come to D.C.
because he has been told by law enforcement he
has to surrender. And that's not what it was. But.
It wasn't the claim that I made. So I'm glad
to get the opportunity to clarify. We have a
fantastic bonus show for you today. It's really.
Speaking of Alex Jones, this is a bonus show
that's going to throw him off his rocker.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
makes money to fund themselves as bad.
Speaker 1: This one's really going to send him for
a loop. Ken Starr, the prosecutor of the Clinton
Whitewater investigation, has died at age 76. This
is one of the earliest political memories I have.
The this investigation done by Ken Starr. We're
going to talk about it on the bonus show. Alabama
may start using nitrogen hypoxia for executions
for a death sentence as executions for people
on death row. What is it? And does this present
new legal problems as Alabama has been plagued
by issues when it comes to executions? And
we are going to talk about the broader based
inflation that we have been seeing recently.
Where is it? What sectors and what are the
implications? All of those stories and more on
today's bonus show. You can get instant access
by signing up at join Packman dot com. We are
also now only five days away from our one day
blowout membership special Monday morning 919.
We are doing a 919 themed membership discount
to try to do a record one day membership drive.
Bigger than we've ever done before. Let's hope
if you want to be notified. Hey, sir or ma'am,
here is the coupon code. Take advantage of it.
You need only sign up for my newsletter at
David Packman dot com and then Monday 919,
you will get that beautiful and clear email
with instructions on how to do it. So for
our current members, we will see you on
the bonus show for our future members.
Look forward to welcoming.
Unidentified: You on Monday.